watch his front and see what he did why
is he doing that I'm attacking it okay
I'm not I'm not playing my turn your
turn to hear the opening is in and I'm
filling it the in space is already
manifested so
okay just like that rather than finding
the right angle you open your grips all
the way so that is spring Here I am i
close my grip rather use your grip to
tell you where the sword goes rather
than you just move the sword where you
want to or become accustomed to and you
let go of the pressure it's the same
thing when he grabs eat he's pushing
right and I'm gonna use that to tell me
where I need to go so the story is
telling me where it needs to go by the
pressure in my grip to go slow boom you
see my maybe I have to loosen this
script opinion on what I want to do but
I should not okay
but if I find the right harmony you see
I can keep that grip keep it cool
they try to get who's there
I'm going to move up the circle and out
of range you don't follow me right
my weapon it should be able to point at
him drill but fill the void you see that
it's not over here it's not over there
it's right in the middle from the skeet
position speed then move boom right
there
okay meet you out on a range and off the
line you see that okay just that my body
is burning TC it turned my body
see that Robin
so when this sweat steps there's already
a rotation in my hips and my body has
already turned and when I finish it then
my body turned for disconnecting the
upper and lower body they do care like
this you see didn't turn your body we do
it this one you got that and you had
this one to do to you got it okay go I'm
here bring this
ladies no more backward
so things need this right Tianna
needed a technique in DeYoung us the art
getting too young me did the Joe so
etcetera etcetera so it's like as I go
on so let's do this so even when he
drops the weapon he's he shouldn't be
aiming it right when he's here like this
he he finds the angle where the weapon
does it not like this you see that
difference Here I am I'm going to move
my right hat and go like that versus
obvious in a turn if I turn the weapon
wants to draw you see and the same thing
goes when I ski there's a park here
where the back of the Joe has to fit
inside the curve of the Eenie
otherwise you get these weird things
where it's on the side of you but when
you get to evocative Tosh it's really
obvious if you're doing it they're gone
okay
so he goes and you come here like this
and you do these weird things you see
that that I'm lifting the Joe up it's
not natural what I'm here like this I'm
just going to make my hand go here
and then my right hand is just going to
follow the joke here see the difference
force
just let the weight of the joke tell you
what it wants to go and that's part of
the arch
in any second you could let go and
adjust the weapon is gonna carry it's
gonna do extend your fun right just
gonna do it stake
okay let's try it so I'm here to stay
there and you're sort person is going to
now provide a guide for you to learn so
I'm going to come to this shielded
position and he will make contact with
my weapon
don't don't drop your hands when you do
that reach out you are now not a sword
as much as you are a line do you
understand that so you know follow up
you just go into this line position then
what my job to do is to reverse this
action on that line so I'm going to come
down around here all the way down
I still have the same naturalness of my
movement
at the end my right hand should be
underneath my Center so I can push on
the joke like I don't want something
that's trying to get up from the ground
to get up
and again if you just if you let go
anywhere in the weapon it's gonna do its
thing you see I'm not forcing it you
force it you're gonna yeah that was
never gonna get there so I'm letting the
weapon tell me where to go
its weight its resistance he's telling
me the natural Taft
okay let's go okay so that is a training
model remember I told you is not a
shortcut he becomes a line that's not
the technique the technique is here I
have to figure out as he's going slow
motion how do I get on this side of his
weapon on this side at the end moment so
I can't be doing things with my weapon
moving it left to right can't happen so
when we go slow he he is aligned and my
job is not to move the line you see that
so I'm gonna go around I'm gonna go
around it you see I'm gonna go around it
you see I'm not gonna move it over here
go back if it just goes down and I allow
the Atocha to do its job she drop you
are confusing displacement with
replacement they're not the same so I
moved so that I can go around it without
lifting it without breaking connection
I'm using him as a guide okay let's go
so I'm gonna take pressure off right now
I'm gonna go around everything right
here and everything is heavy everything
stay there
push on me you see it's not light at the
end it's there's coke you there at that
and I take that and I match the heart
you see go back I'm gonna do the other
one and the Joe's light at the head oh
here around boom
hook you down okay I have IP I pull
around something right but I have to
have you you can't just have my key
so I can't I can't have this gooey
Center to my technique my circle that
the inner core of this of the sphere of
whatever circular action I'm doing does
not mush do you got it and I the
softness you feel in the technique is
that I go around energy it's not from a
mushy Center okay so we're gonna check a
couple ways I need a search person with
no weapon
okay so I go you might hang long so I'm
gonna come sage I'm working on the same
stock look sorry I working on the same
stuff boom
and he's he's gonna test the first one
okay so he's trying to see if there's a
machine or not so I'll make it machine
he goes you see no here okay and then
I'm gonna go down and he will check the
next one he's gonna try to lift up and
he should feel my weight there okay
versus heal it he lifts up whoa
okay so get in three okay so here you
can see if I wanted to hold something
down that's what I would do right some
people mistake of marriage with gravity
with being heavy so they're like I
lowered my body and then I should be
heavy on the joke he goes right and it's
because my weight is not over my jo my
weight is parallel to the Jo
do you understand that's not that's not
what we want so you have to watch how
much you lower your butt okay because
you're going to start to go up you're
going to start to go parallel to the
Joad you see that and you want to be
over the Jo okay let's go so aside from
the parallel waiting that use that you
guys we talked about there's ways you're
making your Jo library so one common way
is that you're going to pull the right
hand off your centerline pipe
now I can't give my weight over it
because he's not under my weight another
way this right
another way is that you don't have the
weapon parallel so you're here and
you're like this and this same thing
you're gonna call it to be lighter or
the other way huh okay so the other way
is this way and it's the same thing
you're gonna cause it to be lighter you
got it so it under my weight my weight
over it alright and the weapon is going
to be parallel to the deck boom
parallel to the deck do you see that not
here not here parallel to the deck under
over
[Music]
so you want to try to activate that rear
posterior chain that's hot AB and do you
got it so you can picture I'm gonna do a
deadlift so I'm going to get that swell
the one right
okay so you're gonna do this down you
need to go move the bar over right fine
so remember in money in my architecture
so click over here okay he pushes on the
joke he's gonna run it it looks soft it
in it but my butt my face is not fall
see that okay and then the same thing
went up what I'm trying to tell you is I
don't there's no gooey Center to it
do you see there's no gooey Center so
right now you guys are getting an
architectural non Ruby center but you
actually have a gooey Center
physiologically okay so I'm gonna enact
all of that healing right I'm here like
that okay so my centers not doing whole
is activated and so it doesn't change it
doesn't change you get it you on the
outside he's starting to get there and I
was trying to get you to do on the
inside with the the urge to not collapse
architecturally quick your you end up
going around it because there's an Ikea
architecture to it and you don't have um
you don't have that flexion okay so your
person's gonna spot check they're in
multiple places
here you go at all supplies right here
you go this is your person Iike okay so
I should find this back foot see
inkelaar
right you know it's not about speed and
then he goes then road is gonna check
him and and this extension is the same
thing this is locked I should be able to
hit him and nothing happens then he goes
down right and the same thing I'm gonna
hit him
sure this this thing it so one two sides
then he's gonna turn right and he's
going to get into that position without
changing anything he's gonna lift on me
go ahead lift the devil okay go